testing one two three  we're on we're here to investigate a  patient that killed three innocent  teenagers on a Halloween in 1978 he was  shot by his own psychiatrist and taken  into custody that night and spent the  last 40 years in captivity hello Michael  I have something you might like to see  everyone in my family like turns into a  nutcase this time of year yeah I mean  your grandmother is Laurie Strode she  was almost murdered wasn't it her  brother who murdered all those  babysitters no it was not her brother  that's the main if people made up do you  know that I pray every night that he  would escape the Bell did you do that  for  so I can kill him the bus crashed  what bus crash Michael escaped  excuse me somebody's in here  [Music]  it's waited for this night he's waited  for me  I've waited for whom  you don't believe in the boogeyman  [Music]  you should you close the closet door  [Music]